bertrand delanoë bonsoir alors on le
voit les premières actions sont très
favorables a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
monde dès le premier jour sur votre
place des filières on me dit 600 milles
mais c'est pas si le chiffre exact
en tout cas j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
heureux heureux dans la beauté de paris
ensemble des parisiens des touristes des
habitants de banlieue je rappelle qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de parisiens
d'habitants de la région parisienne
qu'une partant en vacances c'est d'abord
pour eux et puis si ça donne une image
de paris plus ouvert plus dynamique plus
attirante
c'est peut-être bien aussi pour
l'économie parisienne est-ce que l'an
prochain vous pourriez étendre la plage
rive gauche de la seine puis ce qu on
voyait beaucoup beaucoup de monde
on va voir en tout cas avec mes
collaborateurs et je veux saluer le
personnel de la ville de paris qui a
travaillé par centaines des nuits
entières avec bonne humeur générosité
compétences pour offrir ce plaisir à
tous ceux qui nous visitent aujourd'hui
avec des collaborateurs donc tout à
l'heure on noté ce qui manque et ce qui
n'allait pas on essayer d'entendre aussi
les suggestions donc si on recommence
l'an prochain ce que je souhaite
nous essaierons d'améliorer comme nous
améliorons cette année par rapport à
l'an dernier
est ce que par exemple on a ciselé franc
parisien utiliser davantage les
transports en commun forcément il y aura
davantage d'autobus en circulation
écoutez je vais ou des les maires
précédents s'étaient fixé comme objectif
de faire baisser la circulation
automobile de 5 % 6 ans nous l'avons
fait baisser de 3% en un an
et c'est pas un caprice la l'automobile
c'est la pollution c'est la santé des
plus fragiles et en particulier des
enfants donc faire une ville pour les
habitants pour ceux qui se déplacent par
différents modes qui ne pollue pas c'est
vivre ensemble d'une manière plus
civilisé parce que l'essentiel c'est
quand même la santé est ce que ça veut
dire à terme bertrand delanoë que vous
allez améliorer la circulation pour les
vélos parce que parfois la cohabitation
autobus vélo dans les mêmes voix c'est
pas toujours simple ça s'est amélioré
mais bien sûr que nous voulons corriger
améliorée avec la préfecture de police
nous travaillons régulièrement sur
chaque chantier nous trouvons des
compromis et tout doucement avec une
volonté inébranlable nous
drew paris au parisien et à caen à quand
la baignade avec la plage parce que pour
l'instant évidemment on va se baigner
dans la seine
d'abord il ya déjà beaucoup de jeux pour
enfants beaucoup d'activités sportives
culturelles et de la musique de la
musique classique à l'accordéon à la
guinguette en passant par le jazz ou la
techno et puis c'est vrai je crois que
j'ai oublié votre question parce que
j'étais un peu long mais c'est vrai
aussi que nous voulons que à paris on
puisse se baigner non pas dans la seine
et dans des piscines sur la scène et
donc j'ai promis dans ce mandat de faire
deux piscines dans la scène avec de
l'eau douce évidemment une ce travers le
campus que nous créons avec l'état à
paris rive gauche dans la grande
bibliothèque françois mitterrand et une
autre vers l'ouest de paris dont con on
se baigne rats dans ce cadre magnifique
merci beaucoup aux bertrand delanoë
d'avoir été notre invité ce soir est
bonne promenade sur paris plages
merci